- It's time to crack open our vaults
of never before seen footage.
We're starting with a hilarious story,
actor, Jonathan Tucker told me.
I don't think this needs
any setup, you're welcome.
Well, Jonathan, you posted
this family portrait.
Let's see it, here we go.
- [Guest] Aw!
- [Kelly] Like, oh no,
you are quickly, my man,
not only is this not your family,
it's one of the greatest,
you're the funniest guest I've ever had.
I need you to know that.
- Wait, it is his family, right?
- It's not his family!
(audience laugh)
Why, so tell us what has happened
- I play a lot of serious roles,
so I'm glad that you're pulling
out the humorous side of me
'cause I feel like some
people always think
I'm like the bad guy
or the ultra dramatic.
But you know, I love to
have fun, I love pranks.
I've got great next door neighbors,
Sean and Leslie and
their two beautiful kids.
And we un-burgle a lot.
You know, every time we go over,
we drop something off,
try to hide it away,
tuck it away in their house.
And they actually just moved recently
and discovered a whole slew
of items from wedding gifts
that my wife and I had from 10 years ago
that we couldn't bear to get rid of
except in their, you
know, closet and bathroom,
and other parts of their house.
But Sean was away, you know, dad was away,
and Leslie decided she
was going to do this
mother/daughter family photo shoot.
So I looked out the window and you know,
they're wearing all the same outfits
and the photographer's
out there snapping away.
I was like, "You know what
Sean really would love?
Sean would love a photo of
me stepping into his shoes
in the matching blue and white outfit,
holding his daughter."
If you noticed there,
Kelly, you'll see my hand,
my left hand, it's holding Leslie's arm,
in a gentle embrace, letting her know
that should anything happen
there's always somebody
there to help her out.
- A gentle embrace?
- Sean returned a few weeks later.
He was thrilled!
He's a hot shot talent agent
and all of his clients,
you know, are requesting
photos of this prank.
So it's been a lot of fun.
- It is the greatest prank ever.
- That's amazing.
- Thanks.
- When I saw the photo, I was
like, oh, that's so sweet,
that's his family and they
were like, no, it's not.
(everyone laughs)
It's so great.
You're freaking hilarious.
And just so bold, just be like, yeah,
I'm just going to play dad